es geht um die gasanlage und es geht
darum dass diese gasanlage letztlich
dazu führt dass extra profite der
konzerne noch weiter gesteigert werden
und zwar das zu lasten der
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher und wir
wissen alle dass durch steigende mieten
durch explodierende nahrungsmittelpreise
wir haben heute gesehen inflation steigt
und gerade bei nahrungsmitteln um 16 das
können sich viele familien einfach nicht
mehr leisten und eben durch steigende
energiepreise sind die ohnehin viele
familien mit kleinen und mittleren
einkommen längst am limit und viele
menschen sind bedroht von ihrer sozialen
existenz und deswegen sage ich ganz klar
diese gas umlage muss weg sie schafft
soziale ungerechtigkeit sie gefährdet
menschen und wir sagen ganz klar wir
brauchen einen gaspreis entdecken
beispielsweise im gaspreis er decke wo
gesagt wird man schaut wie war der
gaspreis er vor dem ukraine trieb und
dann an deckelt der stadt dassow das
machen andere europäische staaten auch
machen das erfolgreich spanien portugal
beispielsweise aber sogar auch ungarn
was glaube ich nicht im verdacht steht
irgendwie links zu sein
haben sie mir hier auch dass ihr auch in
deutschland wir brauchen die entlastung
der bürgerinnen und bürger und wir sagen
dass klar wir müssen jetzt die mehrheit
entlasten und wir müssen diejenigen die
großen konzerne die massiv profitieren
jetzt von der krise die müssen wir
stärker belasten sie sprechen
wahrscheinlich von den über gewinn
steuer wenn sie sagen sie wollen
belastend würde ich jetzt tippen das ist
nicht als falsch die über gewinnt steuer
auch das im europäischen ausland in
vielen staaten sowie großbritannien
bossen hat sam gemacht und mit erfolg
bei da lässt sich beispielsweise so was
wie einen gaspreis deckel ja dann auch
sinnvollerweise gegenfinanzieren weil
wir brauchen jetzt in dieser situation
im die entlastung damit leute eben nicht
ihre wohnung im verlieren hat sie noch
am ende des monats wirklich geld haben
um ihre grundbedürfnisse weil sie die
über gewinn steuer in deutschland
steuerrechtlich umsetzen
einfach nur da ganz kurz ich glaube das
wäre jetzt erstmal die frage der
entlastung und das gaspreis am deckel
aber wir haben mittlerweile
unterschiedliche gutachten des
wissenschaftlichen dienstes des
bundestages
das erste mal 2021 das hat die
bundestagsfraktion die linke in auftrag
gegeben weil man damals schon mal dass
im zuge der korona krise eben massive
extragewinne angefangen haben haben eine
frage nicht beantwortet wie wollen sie
steuerrechtlich umsetzen wir wollen
glaube ich ja keine steuerrechtliche
diskussion
der wissenschaftliche dienst des
bundestages hermann schlägt als weg form
annimmt sozusagen die durchschnittlichen
gewinne der beispielsweise letzten fünf
jahre mittel das und das ist will die
macht euer recht denn der steuerrecht
weil das problem ist nicht was sie
vorschlagen die über gewinn steuer die
es aktuell verfassungswidrig in
deutschland
england oder heiße mittleren dienst des
bundestages ja sagt in allen gutachten
die uns vorliegen das sind drei
gutachten zur über gewinnsteuern 13
gutachten sagt der wissenschaftliche
dienst es ist verfassungsrechtlich
möglich und ich glaube wir sollten da
den wissenschaftlichen dienst des
bundestages klaus denke wir sollten wir
auf verschiedenen steuer anmelden und im
steuerrecht glauben schenken es ist
definitiv ein verfassungsrechtliches
kernproblem einer über gewinnsteuern die
gibt es weil die über gewinn steuer wäre
nämlich eine ertragssteuer auf den
gewinnen und das über eine solche steuer
muss bei ein unternehmen gleich sein es
gibt sogar ein fall wo das auch schon
gescheitert ist in den letzten jahren am
verfassungsgericht und dementsprechende
schon meine frage wie das überhaupt
umgesetzt werden soll und zwar war es
nämlich der versuch gewinner einer
branche gezielt abzuschöpfen ist vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht gescheitert im
fall der kernbrennstoffsteuer bekannt
sein die frage ist also wir können ja
nicht einfach die gesetze ein lern
brennstoffsteuer hat der andere
konstruktionsfehler das war nicht das
zentrale problem
meines wissens und das war ein probleme
die bekannt waren die der damalige
minister aber durchaus auch ein kauf
genommen hat da gab es eine relativ
breite debatte in den medien
selbstverständlich kommt darauf an das
verfassungsfest zu machen
selbstverständlich und da kann man sich
keine schnellschüsse erlauben und da
sollte man sich dann auch vielleicht
nicht bei den energiekonzernen beraten
lassen wie es wahrscheinlich bei der
gasanlage
geschehen ist sondern an da sollte man
sich wirklich auch verfassungsrechtler
in dann konzentrieren und die mit
einbeziehen der radio mit deckel denn
ihre partei in berlin vorangetrieben
hatte war ja schon mal nicht
verfassungsfest ja und er wissen sie er
warum weil
reifen ist sechs jahre weil die auskunft
am war und das haben sie ja
wahrscheinlich mitbekommt dass das auf
bundesebene
bundesrechtlich seien vorher klar glaubt
auch damals gab es unterschiedliche
auslegung und fand es richtig dass man
dass man das versucht hat und ich bin
angesichts der situation die wir jetzt
haben ohnehin der ansicht dass wir
mieten decke bräuchten auf bundesebene
zumindest die möglichkeit darauf aber
keine ahnung aber das team war ich dort
wir sollten bremer bleiben ich finds ja
erst mal charmant die idee ist ja
charmant dass man sagt da gibt es krisen
profiteure wie bei jeder krise den nimmt
man das geld weg und die anderen
bekommen ist so und das entscheidende
ist wirklich diese umsetzung also ich
habe angst also ich das ist schon echt
ein massiver markteingriff
mamas wasmund es gibt eine neue steuer
und wir wissen ja alle wenn es eine neue
steuer gibt da bleibt die sehr lange und
ich hab so ein bisschen befürchtung dass
da so ein bürokratisches monstrum
entsteht wo ganz viele beamte die
bilanzen von allen möglichen konzern
durchforsten und dann sagen so
mineralölkonzern xy du musst jetzt das
und das zahlen und dann geht er dagegen
vor vor gericht und der staat profitiert
übrigens auch von den mineralölsteuern
und so weiter aber ich sehe das ähnlich
ich glaube das ist ein riesen problem
bei der umsetzung das hinzubekommen als
idee charmant aber ich glaube aber
wissen sie was in anderen europäischen
staaten immer funktioniert vom sonst
mich auch mal in deutschland
funktionieren warum solltest du in
deutschland liegen die nerven es ist
kein gutes beispiel während die kölner
standort würde zurückwerfen man kann die
länder auch steuer rechtlich überhaupt
nicht machen einfach gleich aber das
stimmt doch irgendwie ganz anders
aufgestellt doch mal ein steuerrecht
nicht mehr länger warten wollen laut
standort stimmt sie haben sondern was
haben wir gerade für ein problem wir
haben doch kein problem dass shell
oder andere große konzerne gerade
notleidend sind und da die haben
teilweise 200 bis 400 im gewinne die sie
gemacht sondern wir haben gerade ein
problem das nicht nur die bürger innen
in deutschland leiden unter diesen
energiepreisen sondern auch das
produzierende gewerbe die kleinen
mittelständischen unternehmen auch die
müssen wir belassen andere kissler
hereinholen und auch eine frage stellen
ist zwar brauchen wir diese steuern also
hat der staat ein problem mit zu wenig
geld einnahmen oder vielleicht eher in
ausgabe also wo liegt da das von
brauchen wir jetzt diese einnahmen um
den armen bürgern den unternehmen zu
helfen braucht der staat noch mehr geld
als bislang gewiss nicht ganz gewiss
nicht der staat hat genügend geld es ist
ein fetter träger aber sehr reicher
staat also sein alter kater also quasi
sehr beleibt aber mehr oder minder
impotent das ist das ist unser ziel
ankommen da ist noch eine neue steuer
drauf zu satteln will mir prinzipiell
nicht einleuchten daher für die schon
interessanter sie sich auf den
sogenannten rechtspopulisten boris
johnson berufen ist auch die sandte
allianz ist ja fast ein kleines hufeisen
und und zum zweiten die unternehmen die
sie genannt haben ich bin kein
steuerexperte aber die unternehmen die
sie genannt haben shell oder bp glaube
ich denke nicht mal deutsche unternehmen
also wie will man jetzt darauf
verpflichten dass sie eine deutschen
steuer- und
so schnell das ist wirklich sehr schön
also aber es ist wie gesagt wir haben
die beispiele wir haben die staaten in
denen es funktioniert wir haben die
studien wir wissen dass wir bis zu 100
milliarden jährlich einnehmen können und
da will ich ihnen was es geht nicht um
den staatshaushalt sondern es geht
wirklich darum mit diesen geldern die
kleinen und mittleren einkommen am ende
haben
sie haben gesagt es geht nicht um den
haushalt aber wenn wir genug geld haben
wozu brauchen wir denn eine neue steuer
dann können wir die menschen doch auch
so entlasten das sind da sind extra
profite die dieser unternehmen machen
und die müssen umverteilt werden wir
haben probleme in deutschland das
momentan sowohl hinter corona krise als
auch in dieser energiekrise die kleinen
und mittleren unter quatsch einkommen
massive verluste ergab
eine studie - m
gerade durch die inflation trotz
steigende löhne das heißt es massives
ein problem und wenn ich weiß nicht ob
sie das schon bekommen haben wir haben
das bekommen von unserem gasanbieter er
schreibt uns herr beuth ihn das mag für
sie verrückt klingen und wir wissen dass
es für sie absolut unvorstellbar ist
aber wir werden zum ende des jahres
mindestens unseren preis dreifachen
müssen dh wir werden unsere rechnung von
1700 auf 1000 5000 euro oder so
gesteigerte bekommen und weitere
steigerungen im nächsten jahr schließen
wir nicht
finden sie das gibt ihnen das recht zu
entscheiden was gut und was böse gewinne
sind das ist ja auch was vor moral zu
sagen okay wir
haben es mit moral zu tun und
unternehmen haben auch in diesem fall
nichts mit moral so wird die über
gewinnsteuern nicht entscheidend ist ein
guter gewinnen was ein schlecht wir
haben da krisen profiteur und wir haben
da kriegst profiteur nichts profitiert
aber selbst das bringt haben user ohne
ja wenn sie das so wollen sind es keine
super tollen gewinnen wo man sagen kann
was man viel sonne und sondern wir
wollen an dieser stelle tatsächlich mehr
gerechtigkeit schaffen und darunter
essen trinken und sterne gewinn winkt am
notwendig an dieser stelle band hat eine
innovation am gemacht und wissen sie ja
auch jetzt halt weiteren mrsa
manchmal ganz so lang man kann an dieser
stelle darüber diskutieren um eine
vernünftige im besteuerung für reden
aber hier an dieser stelle wirklich um
diese energie krise wir reden um die
entlastung von kleinen und mittleren
einkommen wir reden auch über unsere
demokratie weil wenn es so ist dass 60
prozent der haushalte damit jetzt
massive probleme bekommen werden es
bereich
entlasten also das haben sie noch nicht
erklärt warum es die jetzt braucht um
die zu entlasten sie vermischen hier
zwei themen wenden wenn wir die
schuldenbremse weg
dann gebe ich ihm recht ich halte die
schon bremsen nicht für rechtlich hat
sie für eine investitionsbremse müssen
wir ihm wegnehmen
also in dieser logik selbstverständlich
wäre ich vollkommen bei würde ich sofort
an mit ihnen machen leider werden wir
wahrscheinlich wir beide das nicht
entscheiden können und zwar auch nicht
auf was einigen können wer vielleicht
eine rolle wer die einigung schwer
schwierig
sagen wir nicht dass man als verbraucher
ansprechen darf wir reden jetzt darüber
wo milliarden die irgendwo abgeschöpft
worden sind wieder in den staatshaushalt
zurückgeführt werden können und was man
gutes damit machen kann im sinne einer
entlastung die katze dreht sich im kreis
und weiß sich immer wieder in den
schwanz denn die grundproblematik müsste
aus meiner sicht angegangen werden
nämlich die man muss die erkenntnisse
haben die milliarden sind nicht das
problem sondern die kilowattstunden die
in den stromnetzen fehlen ja dh wenn man
schon gezielt nicht man darf nicht nur
steuerlich gezielt entlasten im sinne
ihr müsst ihr werdet jetzt haben wir
mehr geld im geldbeutel
man muss sagen wo kommt denn jetzt der
strom her wird und dass die
atomkraftwerke deswegen würde ich die
frage stellen wo ist denn hier wenn wir
auf ein krisen winter zu gehen auch das
entschlossene krisen-management das sagt
lasst uns mal bitte klar benennen was
das problem ist nämlich nicht 300 euro
mehr im monat im jahr oder den haushalt
oder was auch immer ein geringer
größerer betrag sondern dass der strom
beschafft wird das empfinde ich als
verbraucher als große frechheit im
moment dass hier akademisch über über
gewinnsteuer gasanlagen diskutiert wird
aber man offensichtlich in der debatte
aus meiner sicht momentan vergisst dass
das grundproblem ein mögliches strom
oder gas mangel als solcher ist ja und
da fehlt mir persönlich als bürger das
krisen-management nah dass das habe ich
an dieser stelle für überheblich zu
sagen dass es nicht das problem weil
gehen sie mal mit leuten die wirklich
jetzt am rande ihrer existenz am sind
wir selber geht es aber das war nicht
das rentierlich gemäuer natürlich ist es
ein paar war aber selbstverständlich
haben sie vollkommen recht momentan habe
mit der stromproduktion
haben auch im zuge des klimawandels ein
problem wir lieben große strommengen
haben gerade nach frankreich dabei
wissen die atomkraftwerke sind dort m
die funktionieren teilweise auch im zuge
des klimawandels stichwort andere nicht
das ist ein massives problem aber es
europäische solidarität m wieder
eingefordert ist aber auch frankreich
hatten preis eine decke auf frankreich
ermöglicht den menschen dar über die
runden zu kommen und wir müssen jetzt
ermöglicht den menschen über die runden
zu kommen wir sind sie für die
verlängerung der atomkraftwerke ich
halte die verlängerung der
atomkraftwerke für eine falsche option
weil wir wissen dass würde etwa ein
prozent des gasbedarf es ein erspart
dafür gibt es andere wege dort gibt es
einsparungen bei der industrie auch
einsparungen bei privaten haushalten
durch vernünftige ansätze wodurch man
das gut kompensieren kann und ich halte
das für fahrlässig jetzt zu sagen wir
verlängern in dieser stelle die
laufzeiten es gibt dafür vier songs über
will jedoch sagen wir gehen auf einen
energie notstand zu der im winter
praktisch für jeden bürger gerade für
den bürger mit schmalem geldbeutel
spürbar wird in dem die wohnung nicht
mehr als wird in dem er vielleicht
morgens nicht mehr duschen kann dann
fehlt mir jedes verständnis dafür dass
man da nicht sagt wir müssen dieses
problem konkret angehen durch handlungen
und nicht durch finanzielle umverteilung
haben sie völlig unvorteilhaft ist ein
gutes stichwort für ein kiss leben das
stichwort und sich hier gar nicht mehr
selber moderieren und zwar die kiste
auch etwas mitgebracht was auch im
weitesten sinne von nicht so um
verteilung passt